Start.
[Silence]
No word.
We got Ibraim back today. We got brother
Han back today. We got Abdi back in the
house. We got Aban back. Well, today is
today is quite a day. We have brother J
back today.
Alhamdulillah.
[Silence]
Continuing in ribb
in the 19th book some versions it is the
18th book the book of almanat
and the chapter regarding the narrations
of al
he's also referred to as al-
mas
means that one of his eyes
has been made deficient. It's a synonym
to the word. It's a synonym to the word
oneeyed.
And in another of his terms that the
prophet sallallah.aii Wasallam used to
refer to him which is most widely known
meaning the traveling
the traveling
liar. The one who will travel and
globe trot the earth in search of
followers so that he can take them with
him to the depths of hell.
[Silence]
This narration here is on the authority
of an annis. What is his name? Anisb
and his
Abu Abu Hamza. of Muhamza and Malik and
he was one of the last some say the last
companion to pass away from amongst the
prophet's companions
but he was certainly the last to pass
away in which is where he passed away
narrates that the messenger of Allah
saiam
said there has never been a prophet
except that he has warned his people of
the oneeyed liar. Now, let's take a stop
here for a moment. This word
in English, we would translate this to
oneeyed. Oneeyed. There is a big
difference between one eye,
a person being one eyed and a cyclops,
right? What is a cyclops?
A cyclops is just one eye. never had two
eyes.
One eyed means that he has two eyes but
one of them is deficient. This is
extremely important because
he has been described as
[Silence]
And so the term
In the Arabic language, this is only
used to describe someone who has two
eyes, but one of them is deficient.
So why is this so important? Well, first
of all, it's the description
of this
because if you were around in the '9s, I
know it's starting to feel the '9s
were a million years ago, but during the
'9s and the 2000s when the computer
really the advent of the personal
computer in the home, this wasn't
something that was common until about
around the 90s and early 2000s where
started to be common place to find a
computer in the home, common place to
have internet, common place to have a
television.
Some people
started to have the impression that this
was metaphorical for
right. So they said the television is
the why because it's one eye. See it
just has one eye. The screen is one eye.
is a human being. Yes. The things
perpetrated and propagated on the
internet, on television, on these
mediums may be of
may be of the way of adj may be of the
tools of adj and of the climate of adj.
But they are not adj.cribed
as having two eyes. One of them is
deficient. He's described as having
written on his forehead. He's described
as being very young.
He's described as being very muscular.
As a matter of fact, he's so muscular
that he's hunched. You ever see when
people become so muscular, their back
muscles kind of puff out and they become
almost hunched. This is how he is
described, right? his hair being very
very very coarse and extremely curly.
This these are descriptions of a human
being. These are not descriptions of of
you know to be taken metaphorically.
He said, "There has never been a prophet
except that he has warned his people of
the oneeyed liar.
Indeed, he is oneeyed,"
meaning one of his two eyes is
deficient. And indeed, your Lord is not
one eyed. This is a description of
Allah. Now, correct?
This now is a description of Allah.
In order to understand this, we need to
understand that
just
negating
alone is not a type of praise,
right? It's not a top type type of
praise. Negation alone is not a top type
type of praise. Give you an example.
Let's say
someone wanted to you wanted to marry
your daughter to someone. You come and
you say, "She Ali, I want to ask you
about this guy. What do you think of
this young man?" And then my response
is, "Well, he's not a thief.
He's not a liar."
, well, he's not a he's not a felon.
Do you understand from that that this is
a good guy? What did you understand from
that? Did you understand any praise?
No. This is just purely negating. Pure
negating is not praise. So when we have
for instance Allah says about the Quran
there is no doubt in it.
This alone is not praise. It's only
praise if its opposite is insinuated. If
its opposite is implied, meaning there
is no doubt in it, everything in it is
sure and certain. Now it
becomes praise. Do you understand? If I
say so and so is true, so and so is not
a liar.
And the implication is he tells the
truth always. Now it becomes praise.
Just negating alone is not a type of
praise. So whenever we have a narration
or a verse of the Quran that has a
description of Allah
in the negative meaning it is negating
Allah is not something
we always understand its opposite.
You guys understand? Are you with me? So
for instance when Allah describes
himself
he is not
subdued by by fatigue nor sleep.
This in its own is not praise. The only
time it becomes praise is if we
understand its opposite as being
implied. Meaning he is neither subdued
by fatigue nor sleep. He is ever alive
in the most
in the epitome of what is life for him.
Subhanahu wa ta'ala. That's why right
after this he says
before. So he affirms for himself the
epitome of life and then negates for him
from himself the most minor of death
which is sleep. Understood? The
companions understood from this
narration the description of Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala and they agreed upon
the description that Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala is described as having two eyes.
What are these eyes like? How are these
eyes? This is something that is
unfathomable.
It can never be described to us. The
only thing we know about Allah's
descriptions is that whatever we conjure
up in our imagination, it is not that.
Right? So Allah describes himself as
having a face.
Right?
What does this mean? We understand what
the word face means. It's a face. We
understand. But how is his face? This is
unfathomable. It's not something you
could ever imagine. The only thing you
can be sure of is that anything that the
human being would imagine it is not like
that.
Because Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala says,
None is him in any way. None is
unto him. And he is the
all-heering, allseeing. What does it
mean that he hears? We understand what
hearing is, right? He hears. He's
hearing me right now. How does he hear?
It's impossible for us to know that.
How does he see? He sees me right now.
He's watching us right now. Correct. How
is he watching us?
If I told you
that
a
lobster or a crab
can see in almost 360 degrees around
itself at all times.
Can you imagine what it would be to
see 360 degrees all at once?
Can you imagine that if I told you that
the prophet sallall.aii wasallam in
salah
he was given the ability to see in in
front of him and see also what the
companions behind him. Correct? Can you
imagine what that's like? How was that?
It's impossible to imagine that. You'd
have to experience it first. So when it
comes to the names of Allah, the
attributes of Allah, the descriptions of
Allah, we affirm it as that's what Allah
is.
Allah's face, Allah's hands, Allah's
eyes, Allah's words, Allah hears, Allah
sees. How does Allah see?
How does Allah hear? Unfathomable.
How is Allah's face Allah? How are
Allah's two eyes?
Right? But the companions agreed upon
this and this is one of their evidences
for that that the prophet described
Allah saying
and indeed your Lord is not deficient in
either of his two eyes.
Right? He then goes on to say
written between his eyes. The Arabs when
they say between his eyes, it could
either mean in front of someone or on
their forehead.
This here is considered to be between a
person's eyes. Doesn't necessarily mean
it's on the bridge of their of his nose
here, right?
This is the area that is considered to
be what? Between his two eyes. So the
prophet sallallah.aii wasallam says that
between his two eyes is written the
letters
which is read
because the alif is implied in Arabic
shorthand. The al if is understood to be
there. So it's not written. That's why
it's written this in the Quran. So
it's
what does that mean?
In other wordings of this narration,
every believing man and woman will be
given the ability to read it, whether
they are literate or illiterate.
So in one narration he says
that means that it's written in Arabic
and in another narration
meaning it's spoken
and it is something that every believing
man and woman can read whether they are
literate or illiterate Allahbar.
So when we say the fitna of is very
severe
it is but for the believer
it is very clear is it not soon as you
see him
right
will it be difficult for a person to
bite the bullet yes will it be difficult
to sacrifice
Yes. Will it be unclear? Absolutely not.
[Silence]
[Arabic recitation]